ALRIGHT GOOD MORNING EVERYBODY
AND WELCOME TO OUR JEDI
COMMITTEE ON APRIL SEVENTEENTH.
TODAY AND WE JUST HAVE A SOME
ANNOUNCEMENTS I DO WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT.
YOU KNOW WE DO HAVE A NEW.
COMMITTEE CHAIR WE INTRODUCED
IN LAST TIME THAT WE HAVE BEEN
MORE HEIGHT TO OVER HERE. WE
ALSO HAVE A TO MEMBERS THAT ARE
TEMPORARILY ASSIGNED WE HAVE
MISTER COOLEY WHO IS FILLING IT
SILLY NAM FOR VACANCY. AND.
MISTER GARCIA WILL BE REPLACING
MISTER RODRIGUEZ TODAY WHEN HE
GETS HERE WE ALSO WANT TO IT.
AND WELCOME OUR NEW IN TURN TO
THE JEDI COMMITTEE AND THAT'S
ALEXANDER BUSH RIGHT OUT HERE.
AND HE IS OUR NEW POLICY IN TURN
HE'S A SENIOR AT UC SAN DIEGO
AND HE'S PARTICIPATING IN THAT
YOU SEE. A CENTER AT SACRAMENTO
SO WELCOME. AND I KNOW HE'S
ALREADY BUSY WORKING ON OUR
AGENDA AND WE ALSO HAVE OUR GOOD
FRIEND MR STEINORTH RIGHT BACK
WHERE HE SHOULD BE HERE ON OUR
COMMITTEE HE RAN AWAY FOR A
LITTLE BIT BUT HE'S BACK.
BECAUSE HE KNOWS ALL THAT STUFF
HAPPENS IN THIS COMMITTEE RIGHT.
ALRIGHT SO WE HAVE A VERY QUICK
AGENDA HERE WITH FIVE BILLS ON
FILE WE.
DID WANT YOU TO KNOW THAT AB TWO
SEVEN SIX TO THE CARILLO AND
MURATSUCHI BILL A WAS REMOVED
FOR A LITTLE ADDITIONAL WORK.
AND I'M CONSENT ITEM WE HAVE
ITEM FIVE AB TWO NINE SEVEN FOUR
REYES SO I THINK WHAT WE'RE
GONNA DO IS PUT.
MISTER STEINORTH ASSEMBLY
MEMBER STEINORTH TO WORK RIGHT
AWAY SINCE WE HAVE.
MYSELF IN ASSEMBLY MEMBER I HAD.
IT'S HER FAULT.
IT'S OKAY I GOTTA WAKE UP HERE
LITTLE BIT.
BUT ALSO JUST SO YOU KNOW WE DO
HAVE SOME SUPPLEMENTAL.
SUPPORT IF YOU DIDN'T GET IT
YOU CAN PICK THAT UP AND I THINK
WE'LL GO AHEAD AND BEGAN. YOU.
LIKE THEIR STUFF.
CALLING.
YOU SHOULD CALDWELL.
I EVEN CALLED THE ROLE BECAUSE
WE I THINK WILL ESTABLISH
QUORUM.
CHAIR QUIRK SILVA.
CHAIR QUIRK SILVA HERE.
VICE CHAIR ALAN.
COOLEY.
COOLEY HERE.
BERMAN.
CERVANTES.
CERVANTES HERE.
GARCIA.
STEINORTH.
STEINORTH HERE.
ONE IS ESTABLISH.
MADAM CHAIR.
HE WOULD LIKE TO PRESENT YOUR
BILL.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS.
VERY EXCITED TODAY TO PRESENT
A. B. TWO FOUR SIX THREE ON NOT
ONLY OF MYSELF AS AN AUTHOR BUT
ALSO ASSEMBLY MEMBER CERVANTES
AYE THE SMALL BUSINESS
ASSISTANCE ACT. WE DO WANT TO
ACCEPT THE COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS
AND WE WANT TO LET YOU KNOW THAT
WE BELIEVE THAT.
THIS PARTICULARLY LEGISLATION
IS GOING TO MAKE A HUGE IMPACT
FOR OUR SMALL BUSINESSES. AND
WHEN I CAME TO SACRAMENTO THAT
WAS ONE OF THE THINGS THAT WAS
VERY IMPORTANT AS I HEARD FROM
MANY IN OUR COMMUNITY. UP WE
WANT TO DO THE BEST WE CAN TO
KEEP BUSINESS WORKING IN
CALIFORNIA AND MAKE SURE WERE
THE CHEERLEADERS FOR THOSE
BUSINESSES SO A. B. TWO FOUR SIX
THREE ESTABLISHES A SMALL
BUSINESS ASSISTANCE PROGRAM. FOR
THE PURPOSE OF PROVIDING
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE TO SMALL
BUSINESSES THROUGH PARTNERSHIP
AGREEMENTS AYE WITH FEDERALLY
DESIGNATED SMALL BUSINESS
TECHNICAL CENTERS OR SIMPLE OUR
SMALL BUSINESS DEVELOPMENT
CENTERS. OUT WE HAVE OVER
SEVENTY CENTERS LOCATED
THROUGHOUT THE STATE EACH OF
WHICH ALREADY DENNIS HAS
DEMONSTRATED THE CAPACITY TO
SERVE THE NEEDS OF SMALL
BUSINESSES WELL WE SHOULD
EMPHASIZE EFFICIENTLY UTILIZING
STATE FINDS. AND AGAIN THAT
EFFICIENCY IS SOMETHING THAT I
KNOW MYSELF IN THE CHAIR AND ARE
ON. UP PARTNER ASSEMBLY MEMBER
WE REALLY WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
IF WE'RE PUTTING STATE DOLLARS
INTOCENTERS THAT THEY'RE
SHOWING THE GROWTH THAT WE WANT
TO SEE SO FOR EVERY DOLLAR THE
STATE HAS INVESTED IN THE
CENTERS CALIFORNIA HAS ENJOYED.
IT ROI OF A HUNDRED AND SIXTEEN
TIMES GROWING FROM AN INITIAL
INVESTMENT OF FIVE POINT FIVE
MILLION SMALL BUSINESSES ACCESS
NEARLY A HUNDRED AND FORTY OR
SIX HUNDRED AND FORTY. MILLION
IN NEW CAPITAL.
WITH THAT ASSISTED THROUGH THIS
PROGRAM WOULD ALSO BE USED TO
PROVIDE ONE TO ONE.
CONSULTING AND TRAINING TO
BUSINESSES AND ENTREPRENEURS
AGAIN LISTENING TO THE MEMBERS
IN OUR COMMUNITY WE HAVE FOUND
THAT SOMETIMES A PRESENTATION TO
MANY MEMBERS WORKS BUT SOMETIMES
A REALLY NEED THAT ONE TO ONE TO
REALLY DEFINE THE. UNIQUE
CHARACTERISTICS OF THEIR
BUSINESS IN THIS INDEED DOES
THAT SO I AM EXCITED TO BE AS I
SAID A A JOINT AUTHOR HERE WITH
ASSEMBLY MEMBER AND SHE WILL BE
MAKING HER COMMENTS.
YES GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR
AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS AS A PROUD
JOINT AUTHOR I LIKE TO THINK
ASSEMBLY MEMBER SHARON QUIRK
SILVA FOR ALLOWING ME TO.
PRESENT IN SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY
FOUR SIXTY THREE RELATING TO
SMALL BUSINESS ASSISTANCE ACT OF
TWENTY EIGHTEEN. AS MENTIONED
BEFORE THIS BILL SETS A
FRAMEWORK FOR PROVIDING CRITICAL
RESOURCES TO CALIFORNIA SMALL
BUSINESSES THROUGH PARTNERSHIP
AGREEMENTS WITH THE FEDERALLY
DESIGN SMALL BUSINESS TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE CENTERS.
AS WE KNOW SMALL BUSINESSES ARE
THE BACKBONE OF CALIFORNIA'S
ECONOMY AND THIS IS ESPECIALLY
TRUE IN THE AREA THAT I
REPRESENT.
THE INLAND EMPIRE IS TRULY AN
ECONOMIC FORCE AS IT AS IT IS
ONE OF THE FASTEST GROWING
REGIONS WITH OVER ONE HUNDRED
THOUSAND SMALL BUSINESSES.
AS I KNOW THE UNIQUE CHALLENGES
OF A SMALL BUSINESS OWNER OUR
SHARED EXPERIENCE THROUGHOUT THE
STATE.
WITH THE PASSAGE OF AB TWENTY
SIX FORTY THREE THE STATE WILL
CONTINUE TO SUPPORT OUR SMALL
BUSINESSES BUT THEY'RE NOT JUST
OUR SMALL BUSINESSES ARE SMALL
BUSINESS OWNERS. THROUGH THE
HARD WORK AND MANY OF THE
INDIVIDUALS IN THIS ROOM TODAY
WE ARE PROUD TO INFORM THE
COMMITTEE THAT A HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY ONE ORGANIZATIONS IN A
HUNDRED AND TWENTY TWO
INDIVIDUALS HAVE REGISTERED
THEIR SUPPORT. TO THIS BILL
WITHOUT I WANT TO THANK YOU AND
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE TODAY.
VERY GOOD IF YOU HAVE ANY
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING I WOULD LIKE TO OUT
FIRST OF ALL I THINK THE AUTHORS
OF THIS BILL FOR THEIR
LEADERSHIP. AND A SMALL BUSINESS
AND I WOULD LIKE TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE FOR ITS FOCUS ON SMALL
BUSINESS SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
MY NAME IS JIM WATSON ON THE OF
PRESIDENT OF SEEM TO SEE WE ARE
THE FEDERALLY DESIGNATED
MANUFACTURING EXTENSION
PARTNERSHIP. IN CALIFORNIA WE
ARE TASK BY THE DEPARTMENT OF
COMMERCE TO SERVE SMALL
BUSINESSES WITH A BROAD RANGE OF
SERVICES.
OF BOTH THE MIP PROGRAM AND CMT
C. SUPPORTS THIS BILL WE FEEL
THAT IT LEVERAGES FEDERAL
FUNDING THAT IS COMING TO THE
STATE.
AND BY LEVERAGING THE FEDERAL
FUNDING IT'LL BE ABLE TO PROVIDE
MORE SERVICES TO MORE SMALL
BUSINESSES AND SPECIFICALLY FOR
SANTEE CA AND THE MANUFACTURERS
OF OUR STATE. THAT ALLOW US TO
SERVE MORE OF THE THIRTY NINE
THOUSAND MANUFACTURERS ARE IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA OF
WHICH.
OVER NINETY FIVE PERCENT OF THEM
ARE LESS THAN A HUNDRED PLOY
EASE AND SEVENTY PERCENT OF
THOSE ARE LESS THAN TWENTY
EMPLOYEES SO WE ARE A STATE OF
SMALL MANUFACTURERS.
AND THIS BILL WILL CERTAINLY
HELP KEEP MANUFACTURING IN
CALIFORNIA THANK YOU.
EXCELLENT VERY GOOD ARE THERE
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
COURSE MORNING.
I THINK THE MICROPHONE MIGHT BE
OFF.
GOOD MORNING CURE ALSO BEHALF
THE CITIES OF LOS BANOS IN THE
AREA THAT IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL
EXCELLENT THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
OH OKAY FORGIVE ME. I'M.
I THINK.
DO YOU MIND SERGEANTS YOU MIND
IF WE ITS CAN WE PUT THAT
MICROPHONE ON THIS SIDE.
SORRY THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PATIENCE.
NOPE.
NOT HOOKED UP YET HERE THAT'S
WHEN I GOT IT.
ALRIGHT I THINK YOU LIVE NOW.
IT'S.
I THINK YOUR LIFE OKAY FAQ. GOOD
MORNING MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS
OF THE ASSEMBLY TEDDY COMMITTEE
LAURIE CAMERON REPRESENTING
SMALL BUSINESS CALIFORNIA
OPPORTUNITY FUND AND THE
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF WOMEN
BUSINESS OWNERS ALL VERY MUCH IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING SEAN LIST OF THE
NATIONAL FEDERATION OF
INDEPENDENT BUSINESS
REPRESENTING OVER TWENTY
THOUSAND SMALL BUSINESS OWNERS
ALSO IN SUPPORT AS VDCS PROVIDE
A GREAT RESOURCE TO SMALL
BUSINESSES ACROSS THE STATE. WE
SUPPORT THIS BILL THANK YOU.
EXCELLENT VERY GOOD.
MORNING I DAY BUTLER
REPRESENTING UNITED CHAMBER
ADVOCACY NETWORK A GROUP OF FIVE
LOCAL CHAMBER ORGANIZATIONS HERE
IN THE SACRAMENTO REGION. ALSO
IN SUPPORT WE'RE VERY GRATEFUL
THAT THE AUTHOR IN THE
ADMINISTRATION CHOSE TO LEVERAGE
THE EXISTING SMALL BUSINESS
DEVELOPMENT CENTER NETWORK WHICH
IS A A GREAT SYSTEM OF SUPPORT
FOR SMALL BUSINESS THROUGHOUT
THE STATE THANK YOU.
I MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS ALL OVER
AWKWARD CALIFORNIA LIFE SCIENCES
ASSOCIATION OTHER BIOTECH
INDUSTRIES THE PITY ME HAVE YOU
START SMALL AND EVENTUALLY YOU
GET TO BE. BIGGER SO PROVIDING
THEM WITH ADDITIONAL TOOLS AND
RESOURCES THAT IS A WONDERFUL
OPPORTUNITY IN. STRONG SUPPORT
OF THE BILL AGAIN THANK YOU.
HELLO MY NAME'S TIM YAMAUCHI ON
THE DIRECTOR OF THE MINORITY
BUSINESS DEVELOPMENT AGENCY
EXPORTS CENTER HERE IN
SACRAMENTO.
AND I'M REPRESENTING THE KELLY
XIN CHAMBER WHICH OPERATES IT WE
OFFER SUPPORT.
I GET THANK YOU.
I AM RUBEN FRANCO IN THE
PRESIDENCY OF THE ORANGE COUNTY
HISPANIC CHAMBER IN THE PROUD
HOST OF A SMALL BUSINESS
DEVELOPMENT CENTER AS WELL WITH
WITH CAL STATE FULLERTON.
WHERE IN SUPPORT OF THE
LEGISLATION THANK YOU?
TITANS.
HI MY NAME IS MIKE DANIEL AND I
CUT AND.
WE DON'T DIRECTOR FOR THE
ORANGE COUNTY RIVERSIDE SOMEBODY
KNOW.
SMALL BUSINESSWOMAN CENTERS AND
WE AND REPRESENT ALL FORTY FIVE
S. B. C.'S ACROSS OUR STATE. WE
THINK THAT THE CHAIRWOMAN FOR
PUTTING THIS BILL TOGETHER ALONG
WITH US ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CERVANTES AND THAT WE SUPPORT
THE BILL SO THANK YOU. EXCELLENT
VERY GOOD THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS HEIDI PICKMAN I'M
WITH CAMEO THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION FOR MICRO ENTERPRISE
OPPORTUNITY WITH A STATEWIDE
NETWORK OF MICRO LENDERS AN
ENTREPRENEURIAL TRAINING.
PROGRAMS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA FROM SAN DIEGO ALL
THE WAY UP TO A WEEK INCLUDING
THE SPD SEASON THE WOMEN'S
BUSINESS CENTERS. AND SOME OF
THE P. TAX AND SOME OF THE OTHER
ORGANIZATIONS THAT PROVIDE
FEDERAL SMALL BUSINESS.
SYSTEMS AND WE ARE VERY MUCH IN
FAVOR OF THIS BILL.
I GET THANK YOU.
HELLO MY NAME IS FATIMA ORI I'M
THIRD DIRECTOR OF THAT LIMITS
BUT ONE SETTLER IN THE
RENAISSANCE ENTREPRENEURSHIP
CENTER IN SAN FRANCISCO AND WE
VERY MUCH ARE IN SUPPORT OF THIS
BUT I THINK YOU.
THANK YOU.
HELLO MY NAME IS MARIAM PETRILLO
AND I'M EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR WES
COMPANY IN MENDOCINO COUNTY. WE
RUN BOTH A SMALL BUSINESS THE
WOMEN'S BUSINESS CENTER AS WELL
AS A SMALL BUSINESS DEVELOPMENT
CENTER. WE ARE VERY MUCH IN
FAVOR OF THIS LEGISLATION AND WE
WANT TO THANK EACH AND EVERYONE
OF YOU FOR TAKING THE TIME OUT.
TO TO ORGANIZE THIS AND WE ARE
REALLY THRILLED TO BE HERE THANK
YOU.
THE MY NAME MY NAME IS GARY
BELSKY I'M A WITH A SMALL
BUSINESS DEVELOPMENT CENTERS
REPRESENT A NORTHERN CALIFORNIA
HERE IN SACRAMENTO. AS WELL AS
THE STATE.
VERY APPRECIATIVE OF THIS I
MEMBERS FOR PUSHING THROUGH THIS
BILL AND REALLY EXCITED TO WORK
WITH THE OTHER T. PROVIDERS.
LIKE THE MBTA'S THE TO HIS
BUSINESS CENTERS IN THE
MANUFACTURING ENTERPRISE PROGRAM
THANK YOU.
I MARK HURLBERT CALIFORNIA
DIRECTOR FOR SMALL BUSINESS
MAJORITY VERY NATIONAL SMALL
BUSINESS EDUCATION AND ADVOCACY
ORGANIZATION AND WE'RE THRILLED
TO SUPPORT THIS REALLY IMPORTANT
BILL.
THANK YOU.
HELLO OUT NIGHT AND HOWERTON THE
REGIONAL DIRECTOR FOR CENTRAL
CALIFORNIA SBDC NETWORK AND
WE'RE THRILLED TO SEE THIS BILL
COME FORWARD AND TO. SAY THE
SUPPORT OF THIS COMMITTEE.
ON THE SUPPORT THEY NEED FOR
SMALL BUSINESS THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
THANK YOU.
TIMOTHY KELLY I'M A BOARD MEMBER
OF A PER REGION ALLIANCE THE
HOST OF THE IMPERIAL VALLEY
SMALL BUSINESS DEVELOPMENT
CENTER PART OF SAN DIEGO AND
PREVAILING NETWORK AND WHERE
IT'S PART OF THIS BILL.
EXCELLENT THANK YOU ARE THERE
ANY OTHER WITNESSES AND SUPPORT.
MAY I INVITE ANY WITNESSES IN
THE OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE.
MAY BRING IT BACK TO COMMITTEE
FOR ANY QUESTIONS.
SCULLY NO.
MASS FOR A MOTION.
BILL SECOND EXCELLENT WE HAVE A
MOTION AND A SECOND I WOULD LIKE
TO TAKE A BACK TO THE AUTHORS TO
SEE IF THEY HAVE WOULD LIKE TO
CLOSE.
I WOULD JUST LIKE TO THANK ALL
THE BUSINESS REPRESENTATIVES
THAT CAME OUT TODAY WE KNOW THAT
THEY ARE.
WORKING WITH BUSINESS OWNERS OR
ARE RUNNING THEIR OWN BUSINESSES
AND TO TAKE THEIR TIME TO
SUPPORT THIS BILL MEANS A LOT WE
ALSO KNOW THAT WITH OUR STACK OF
LETTERS.
THAT.
THE BUSINESSES MEAN BUSINESS
AND WE.
ARE THANKFUL TO BE ABLE TO
PRESENT THIS ON THEIR BEHALF
FROM APPS FOR YOUR AYE VOTE
EXCELLENT VERY GOOD SO I JUST
LIKE THEY'RE JUST APPLAUD BOTH
AUTHORS ASSEMBLY MEMBER QUIRK
SILVA CERVANTES FOR BRINGING
THIS BILL FORWARD AYE. I APPLAUD
YOUR COMMITMENT TO SMALL
BUSINESS SENSE AS A BIT SMALL
BUSINESS MAN I I THINK IT'S
FANTASTIC IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA HAS GREATLY BENEFITED
FOR THIS. THE MOTION IS TO PASS
AS AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS IF
WE COULD PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ITEM NUMBER THREE AB TWENTY FOUR
SIXTY THREE.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
IN RE REFER TO ASSEMBLY
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
CHAIR QUIRK SILVA I'VE.
SHARE QUIRK SILVA AYE.
VICE CHAIR ALAN.
COOLEY.
COOLEY AYE.
BERMAN.
CERVANTES.
CERVANTES AYE.
GARCIA.
GARCIA I.
STEINORTH I.
STEINORTH ONLY.
EXCELLENT YOUR BILL WITHOUT.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT ABOUT THE
CHAIRS BUT I SEEM TO BE SITTING
IN THIS. SPECIFIC.
KIND OF TO FIGURE OUT HOW TO GET
THAT CHAIR TO MOVE UP.
ALRIGHT BUT WE ARE GOING TO GO
AHEAD IN NOW MOVE TO ITEM ONE A.
B. TWO THREE ONE TWO UP ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS GARCIA.
TAXATION.
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR AND.
MEMBERS OF THIS COMMITTEE I
PRESENT TO YOU A. B. TWENTY
THREE TWELVE.
AS A TWO POINT FOUR TRILLION
DOLLAR ECONOMY CALIFORNIA
REMAINS AN ATTRACTIVE PLACE FOR
BUSINESS.
HOWEVER OTHER STATES HAVE
RECENTLY PROVIDED INCENTIVES FOR
BUSINESSES TO START NEW
INVESTMENTS IN THEIR RESPECTIVE
STATES.
AND NOT SO MUCH HERE IN
CALIFORNIA.
AB TWENTY THREE TWELVE WOULD
ALLOW THE STATE TO REMAIN
ECONOMICALLY COMPETITIVE AS WELL
AS ATTRACT JOB CREATION. AND
RETENTION.
BUSINESSES AT OUR REGION THE
SIGNIFICANT TO THE AREA IN
QUESTION WOULD BE ABLE TO
BENEFIT FROM MAYBE TWENTY THREE
TWELVE. IF THEY MEET CERTAIN
HIRING AND INVESTMENT TARGETS
SET FORTH.
IN WRITING WITH GOLD IS.
THE AWARD CAN BE USED TOWARDS A
TAXPAYERS LIABILITY AND CAN BE
UTILIZED IN SUBSEQUENT YEARS IF
THEIR TAX LIABILITY IS LESS THAN
THE AWARD. AWARDED AMOUNT.
AB TWENTY TWELVE WILL HELP.
INCENTIVIZE BUSINESSES WHO WISH
TO DO WORK IN OUR STATE BY
GIVING THEM MORE CERTAINTY
REGARDING ECONOMIC RESOURCES.
AND INCENTIVES
BY GIVING LOCAL GOVERNMENTS THE
TOOLS TO PROPERLY INCENTIVIZE
BUSINESSES THEY WILL BE BETTER
SUITED. TO PROVIDE STABILITY AND
RETAIN MORE CONTROL OVER THEIR
ECONOMIC GROWTH.
I'M PLEASED TO CONFIRM THAT I AM
ACCEPTING THE PROPOSED COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS WE VIEW THEM AS
IMPORTANT POSITIVE REFINEMENTS
TO THE BILL AND THANK THE
COMMITTEE AND STAFF FOR THE
SUGGEST IMPROVEMENTS. THAT WITH
ME TODAY HAVE A TING CALLIE
PRESIDENT IMPAIR VALLEY ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT CORPORATION HERE TO
SPEAK ON BEHALF OF AB TWENTY
TWELFTH.
THANK YOU WELCOME.
THANK YOU ULTRA WOMAN QUIRK
SILVA.
I'M COMMITTEE IT'S IT'S HONORED
HERE TODAY.
AND THE PRESIDENCY KNOW THEM
PEARL VALLEY ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT CORPORATION IMPERIAL
COUNTY. IS THE ONLY COUNTY IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA BORDERS
ANOTHER COUNTRY IN ANOTHER
STATE.
AND WE ARE VERY COMPETITIVE WITH
BOTH MEXICO AND ARIZONA BY TAB
WITH CIVIL INSTANCES. IN WHICH
WERE NOT ABLE TO COMPETE AT A
LEVEL IN WHICH ARE ABLE TO
RETAIN. AND ATTRACT BUSINESSES
I THIS BILL IS GOING TO ALLOW US
TO DO THAT AT THE LOCAL LEVEL TO
BE ABLE TO. A MARKET THE REGION
BETTER BUT I WANT TO BRING UP A
COUPLE POINTS IN FIRST ONE HAS
TO DO WITH THE RETENTION. A
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA WE SEE A
LOT OF MERGERS AND ACQUISITIONS
AND MANY OF THESE. AYE MERGERS
HAVE BEEN WITH COMPANIES THAT
OPERATE BOTH IN CALIFORNIA AND
ARIZONA. A ONE SUCH COMPANY
FRESH EXPRESS.
ACQUIRED ACCOMPANYING KILLED
CALIFORNIA WHICH ALSO OWNED A
COMPANY IN YUMA ARIZONA.
AND THAT IN DECIDING TO CLOSE
ONE OF THOSE ONE OF THOSE
LOCATIONS BECAUSE ONLY SIXTY. A
MILES APART THEY CLOSE LOCATION
IN EL CENTRO DISPLACING OVER A
HUNDRED TWENTY SEVEN EMPLOYEES
WITH. A ANCILLARY BENEFIT OR
BENEFIT ARIZONA WAS GREAT
BENEFIT BUT TO OUR REGION WAS
PROBABLY ABOUT FOUR HUNDRED
EMPLOYEES.
AND THAT'S WHAT'S IS ONE EXAMPLE
OF OF HOW THIS TELETYPEWRITER
GRAHAM COULD HAVE. A THROUGH OUR
A RAPID RESPONSE EFFORTS COULD
RETAIN THAT TYPE OF COMPANY. AND
YET THROUGH THE YOU CAL COMPETES
PROGRAM IT'S A PROCESS THAT
TAKES A LOT OF TIME IN OUR OUR
DECISION OR THE DECISION OF THE
COMPANIES WITHIN ABOUT. THIRTY
DAYS A CAL COMPETE PROGRAM CAN
WORK AND DOES WORK AYE US GYPSUM
IS AN EXAMPLE OF THAT.
THEY DID EXPANSION HERE IN
CALIFORNIA WHERE COMPETING GETS
NEVADA WOULD BEST BUT A SIX
MONTH PROCESS NOR PREPARE
PREPARE FOR THAT. AND IN DOING
SO WE'RE ABLE TO CAPTURE CAL
COMPETES TAX CREDITS AND THEIR
DECISION WAS TO NOT ONLY STAY
CALIFORNIA BE EXPAND. AND CREATE
ABOUT A HUNDRED JOBS THAT
PROCESS TOOK ABOUT SIX MONTHS TO
A YEAR. BUT DURING THAT TIME
WERE ABLE TO MOVE FORWARD VERY
QUICKLY. WHEN WE'RE TRYING TO
ATTRACT COMPANIES TO CALIFORNIA
WE DON'T HAVE THAT TIME.
AB WE HAVE LITERALLY DAYS.
TO MAKE DECISIONS AND PROVIDE
INFORMATION TO COMPANIES.
IN A COUPLE MONTHS I WILL BE
GOING TO WASHINGTON DC IN
COOPERATION WITH GOBIZ TO SELECT
USA. WILL BE MEETING WITH
HUNDREDS OF COMPANIES COMPETING
AGAINST ALL STATES IN THE UNITED
STATES.
FOR FOREIGN DIRECT INVESTMENT
FOR THOSE A COMPANIES LOOKING TO
INVEST IN UNITED STATES AND WHAT
WE CONTINUALLY SEE. IS THE LACK
OF THE TOOLS THAT WE HAVE HERE
IN CALIFORNIA A TO BE ABLE TO
TRACK THOSE COMPANIES.
THAT CALIFORNIA IS IS GREAT
STATE WE HAVE A GREAT GREAT
PROGRAMS BUT WHEN IT COMES TO BE
ABLE TO TO MAKE DECISIONS AT THE
LOCAL LEVEL PROVIDE INCENTIVES.
TO COMPANIES TO MAKE A DECISION
TO COME TO CALIFORNIA WE LIKE
THOSE THIS BILL IS GOING TO
ALLOW THAT TO HAPPEN. AS RESERVE
DOLLARS FOR THE FUTURE TO BE
CARRIED OVER SO THE LOCAL LEVEL
WE CAN MOVE PROJECTS FORWARD
QUICKER. AND GIVE AND GIVE
COMPANIES THAT ARE INTERESTED IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. AL A
RELIEF KNOWING THAT WE'RE
WORKING WITH THEM AND THE
PROCESS IS NOT ONLY HOPE. BUT
IT'S IT'S IT'S CLOSER TO
GUARANTEE THAT THERE WILL BE AN
INCENTIVE OF THOSE COMPANIES
DECIDE TO COME TO CALIFORNIA.
LIKE I SUPPORT THIS BILL I THINK
IT'S VERY IT WILL BE VERY
HELPFUL IN OUR TRACTION EFFORTS.
BUT IN ADDITION TO THAT IT'S
GOING TO BE A VERY VALUABLE TOOL
IN THE RETENTION. AND EXPANSION
EFFORTS THAT WE HAVE HERE IN THE
STATE CALIFORNIA.
OKAY THANK YOU DO WE HAVE ANY OF
OUR MEMBERS HERE THAT HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS FOR THE AUTHOR OR ARE
SUPPORT WITNESS.
DOESN'T LOOK LIKE AT THIS TIME
DO WE HAVE ANYBODY ELSE WOULD
LIKE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT.
ALRIGHT DO WE HAVE ANYBODY
SPEAKING IN OPPOSITION.
RIGHT ANY OTHER QUESTIONS BEFORE
WE ASK OUR AUTHOR TO CLOSE.
I AM I WOULD LIKE TO JUST SAY I
THINK THIS IS A GREAT PROGRAM IN
A GREAT A PIECE OF LEGISLATION I
WANNA COMPLEMENT THE AUTHOR I
UNDERSTAND WILK HILL FROM LOCAL
GOVERNMENT AND IT'S A BIT OF A
CHALLENGE FOR US TO RETAIN. OUT
OF THE BUSINESSES THAT ARE
LOOKING TO MOVE ON AND THEN TO
ATTRACT NEW BUSINESSES TO OUR
COMMUNITIES I THINK THAT THIS IS
GOING TO BE A VALUABLE TOOL. AND
IF YOU WOULD CONSIDER ADDING ME
AS COAUTHOR IS IT MOVES THROUGH
THE LEGISLATION I'D BE GREATLY
HONORED.
YES I LIKE TO THINK THE AUTHOR
FOR BRINGING THIS BILL FORWARD I
FULLY SUPPORTED IN MY TO ALSO BE
ADDED AS A CO AUTHOR.
YOU DIDN'T.
BUT WHEREVER.
MOTION TO MOVE IN A SECOND AND
YOU DID ACCEPT THE AMENDMENTS I
JUST HAVE ONE QUESTION AGAIN
JUST A LITTLE TESTIMONY ON WHAT
THIS BILL WOULD LOOK LIKE GIVING
AN EXAMPLE OF THE BUSINESS. I
LIKE TO DO THAT BECAUSE IN THIS
ROOM WERE KIND OF A PEOPLE THAT
ARE READING ALL THE LEGISLATION
BUT BELIEVE IT OR NOT WE
ACTUALLY HAVE PEOPLE WHO WATCH
THESE HEARINGS THAT AREN'T IN
THE ROOM AND I LIKE THEM TO
REALLY UNDERSTAND. A WHAT IS IT
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT HERE BECAUSE
THE BILL IF YOU. THE TITLE SAYS
A TAXATION SO GIVES AN EXAMPLE
OF HOW THAT LOOKS
WELL YEAH SO AM. I THINK. ONE OF
THE AND ONE OF THE CHALLENGES IS
WITH CAL COMPETES PROGRAM IS NOT
ALL OF THE DOLLARS A UTILIZED IN
A GIVEN YEAR. AND THIS ALLOW FOR
CARRY OVER BUT IN ADDITION TO
THAT TO DEDICATE. THOSE FUNDS
THROUGH A LOCAL LEVEL TO WEAR AS
WERE MARKETING OUR REGION. THEN
WE WOULD BE ABLE TO MARKET AND.
IN A WAY THAT SAYS THAT WE HAVE
TAX CREDITS ARE AVAILABLE. THAT
WE CAN SUPPORT YOUR BUSINESS
AND AND THE ARMS. CAL COMPETES
PROGRAM IS STILL IN PLACE THIS
IS DISTANT DECISIONS ARE STILL
MADE. AT THE COMMITTEE LEVEL BUT
IT GIVES THEM THE LOCAL AT THE
LOCAL LEVEL WE HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY. TO UTILIZE THE CAL
COMPETES IN A IN A WAY THAT'S
GOING MAKE UP THOSE COMPANIES
MORE COMPETITIVE. FOR ON THE TAX
CREDITS AND IT'S GOING ALLOWED
THE COUNTIES AND CITIES. TO
SUPPORT THOSE BUSINESSES AND I
THINK THAT THAT.
IS GOING BENEFIT AND NOT ONLY
IN THE ATTRACTION EFFORTS BUT
ALSO IS GOING BENEFIT IN
UTILIZING THIS TAX CREDITS TO
RETAIN. AND COMPANIES IN OUR
REGION.
OKAY SO AGAIN JUST TO CLARIFY IF
YOU WERE OUT THERE IN A BUSINESS
ENVIRONMENT WHETHER IT BE HERE
IN CALIFORNIA OR ANOTHER STATE
DC. AND THEY'RE REALLY TRYING TO
MAKE THAT DECISION ABOUT WHERE
DO THEY REALLY WANT TO SET UP
SHOP IF YOU WANT TO SAY IT THAT
WAY. AND WE CAN NOW SAY WE CAN
CONFIDENTLY SAY THAT THERE WILL
BE SOME TYPE OF SUPPORT THROUGH
TAX CREDITS THIS COULD MAKE THE
DIFFERENCE OF FROM THE FOR THEM
DECIDING TO STAY HERE IN
CALIFORNIA SO. AS YOU CAN SEE OF
THAT TYPE OF ASSURANCE I THINK
IS WHAT BUSINESSES HAVE BEEN
ASKING US MANY TIMES IS WE NEED
THE CONFIDENCE TO KNOW THAT
WE'RE GOING TO HAVE THE SUPPORT
SO. THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND WE
HAD A MOTION TO.
TO MOVE FORWARD IN A SECOND AND.
MISTER SECRETARY.
ITEM NUMBER ONE ASSEMBLY BILL
TWENTY THREE TWELVE.
THE MOTION IS DO PASS AS AMENDED
AND RE REFER TO THE ASSEMBLY
COMMITTEE ON REVENUE AND
TAXATION. CHAIR QUIRK SILVA.
VICE CHAIR ALAN.
COOLEY.
COOLEY AYE.
BERMAN.
CERVANTES.
CERVANTES AYE.
GARCIA.
STEINORTH.
STEINORTH I.
OKAY THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY
MUCH AND I THINK ARTS OF A
MEMBER EDUARDO GARCIA FOR
SPONSORING THIS BILL AND THANK
YOU FOR YOUR SUPPORT OF THE BILL
THAT BILL OLBIA PUT ON CALL.
ALRIGHT AND JUST TELL A QUICK
ANNOUNCEMENT WE ACTUALLY ARE NOT
GOING TO HAVE.
THIS AS AB TWO NINE SEVEN FOUR
ON CONSENT.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER RATES WILL
ACTUALLY BE PRESENTING THAT SO.
ALRIGHT SO WE'RE GONNA GO AHEAD
AND MOVE TO ITEM TO AB TWO FIVE
NINE SIX CALIFORNIA ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT STRATEGIC PLAN AND
WE HAVE.ASSEMBLYMEMBER COOLEY
HERE.
WELL COULDN'T A ASSEMBLYMEMBER
COOLEY AND MEMBERS OUT THERE WE
HAVE SOME EXCITEMENT GOING ON IN
THIS COMMITTEE WE HAVE CHARTS.
ETHNIC. HOW KINDS OF THINGS
ALRIGHT ASSEMBLY MEMBER? COOLEY.
WELL COLLEAGUES I AM VERY
PLEASED TO BE HERE TODAY
PRESENTED AB TWENTY FIVE NINETY
SIX.
AND THE OBJECT OF THIS BILL IS
REALLY.
TO TAKE A LOOK AT OUR ECONOMIC
STRENGTH IN CALIFORNIA LOOK AT
THE FRAILTIES.
LOOK AT HOW DO WE PRODUCE A LONG
TERM STRATEGIC APPROACH TO
GROWING OUR ECONOMY.
WHICH IS VITAL NOT JUST TORE
CITIZENS BUT REALLY GLOBALLY.
GLOBALLY SIGNIFICANT CALIFORNIA
PAVING THE WAY CREATING JOBS.
.
SO THE AIM OF THIS BILL IS TO
DEVELOP A CALIFORNIA ECONOMIC.
DEVELOPMENT STRATEGIC PLAN.
AND.
IDEF ONE A NOTE THANK. THE
COMMITTEE FOR THEIR WORK WITH
AMENDMENTS ITEM COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS.
JUST THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PARTICIPATION TONY SIMON'S WHO
I'VE KNOWN SO LONG THANK YOU FOR
YOUR WORK.
.
AND BECAUSE WE ARE TALKING JOBS
OF COURSE IS THE MOMENT WHEN YOU
YOU POINT OUT THE CALIFORNIA'S
THIS WORLD SIX LARGEST ECONOMY.
BUT WHATEVER I HERE THAT I FEEL
LIKE OUT A WHISTLE A FEW BARS.
THERE'S AN ASPECT OF AFFIRMING
THAT WHICH IS CERTAINLY TRUE
IT'S A LITTLE BIT LIKE WHISTLING
PAST THE GRAVEYARD.
HOW DO WE SUSTAIN OUR ECONOMY
HOW DO WE GROW OUR ECONOMY?
WHISTLING PAST THE GRAVEYARD IS
WHAT YOU DO TO CHEER YOURSELF
UP.
WHEN YOU YOU WANT TO BE CHEERED
UP SO WE ARE THE SIX LARGE
ECONOMY BUT WE DO NEED TO BE
GROWING. GROWING CONSTANTLY.
AND.
.
DESPITE OUR STATUS AS THE SIX
LARGE ECONOMY CALIFORNIA DOES
HAVE. SOME ECONOMIC CHALLENGES
WHICH ARE CRITICAL.
.
OUR PROSPERITY IS LOCALIZED
AROUND THE STATE'S WRITTEN
REGION STATE ABOUND OTHER
PLACES.
ECONOMIC GROWTH IS POOR MEAGER
THIS AFFECTS ECONOMIC
OPPORTUNITY THE SENSE OF HOPE
ACROSS RURAL STATE.
AND SO THOSE INEQUITIES.
ARE BOUND UP IN THIS QUESTION
HOW DO WE GROW OUR ECONOMY.
THEREFORE THIS BILL IS REALLY A
LEADERSHIP BILL.
AND BEFORE I TURN TO MY
WITNESSES.
I'D LIKE TO OFFER A FEW COMMENTS
ABOUT HOW I THINK ABOUT
LEADERSHIP AND WHY THIS BILL
FITS INTO THAT.
IN ITS MOST BASIC FORM
LEADERSHIP IS.
CAN BE SUMMARIZED IN THE PHRASE
YOU CANNOT BLOW AN UNCERTAIN
TRUMPET.
IF YOU WANT SOMETHING TO HAPPEN
YOU NEED TO BE CLEAR AND
COMPELLING. AND ON THAT MESSAGE
ALL THE TIME.
AND THAT IS THAT IS IMPORTANT TO
LEADERSHIP.
BLOWING A CLEAR COMPELLING
TRUMPET.
BUT IT'S NOT ENOUGH.
YOU ALSO NEED TO GET DOWN AND
SAY WELL WORDS LEADERSHIP NEED
HAPPENED ONE OF THE CHALLENGES
HOW DO YOU DIVERT THOSE WE TO
START TO HAVE AN IMPACT.
A AND THAT ACTUALLY IS WORK.
IT'S INTELLECTUALLY BRITS ARE
WORKERS LAWMAKERS.
A.
A FAVORITE COMMENT ON THIS ON
THIS CHALLENGES ONE OF FDR.
WHO?
ACTUALLY APPOINTED MY
GRANDFATHER POSTMASTER OF
HEALDSBURG CALIFORNIA.
FDR LIKE TO SAILORS REMEMBERED
FOR SAYING THE TEST OF A FIRST
RATE INTELLIGENCE.
IS YOU HAVE TO HAVE THE ABILITY
TO HOLD TWO OPPOSED IDEAS IN THE
MIND OF THE SAME TIME.
ONE SHOULD FOR EXAMPLE BE ABLE
TO SEE THAT THINGS ARE HOPELESS.
AND YET BE DETERMINED MAKE THEM
OTHERWISE.
AND I THINK WHEN YOU START
LOOKING TO IT ISSUE LIKE HOW DO
WE REALLY IS. PUBLIC POLICY
MAKERS.
LABOR TO GET A MORE SYSTEMATIC
APPROACH TO GROWING BUSINESS IN
CALIFORNIA. GIVEN THE SCALE THE
MAGNITUDE OF CALIFORNIA AT US
BOTH A DAUNTING. ALMOST HOPELESS
PROSPECT.
BUT ONE BEGUN WORK ON.
AND.
SO THEN IT BECOMES OF HIM
SOLUTION PROBLEM HOW DO YOU WORK
ON IT.
I HAVE A QUOTE FOR THAT TOO
THAT'S THOMAS EDISON.
THOMAS EDISON THE GREAT INVENTOR
WHO SAID.
THERE CAMINO. THERE COULD BE NO
PROGRESS.
UNTIL A SUFFICIENT NUMBER OF
PEOPLE ARE BROUGHT.
BECOME DISSATISFIED.
THE WAY THINGS ARE.
AND THIS CAN ONLY HAPPEN WHEN
THEY'RE BROUGHT THINK BEYOND THE
LIMITS TO WHICH THEIR CUSTOM.
SO I THINK A CONVERSATION ABOUT
OUR GREAT ECONOMY HOW BOOM IT IS
DOZEN TAIL LOOKING AT WHAT ARE
THE WEAKNESSES.
ONE OF THE THINGS WE HAVE TO BE
DISSATISFIED ABOUT.
AND REALLY.
ONE OF THE PROSPECTS FOR
IMPROVEMENT THAT WE CAN TARGET.
WHICH IS WHAT THIS BILL IS GOING
AFTER.
AND THIS THEN CONCLUDES BEFORE
WITH MY OWN QUOTED MYSELF THERE
IS A LEADERSHIP SYLLOGISM FOR
HOW YOU MOVE PEOPLE FORWARD.
AND BASS INVOLVES SAYING HERE'S
WHERE WE ARE TODAY WHICH IS BAD
FOR THE FOLLOWING REASONS.
HERE'S VERY BE TOMORROW WHICH IF
WE DID THAT WOULD BE BETTER FOR
THE FOLLOWING REASONS.
HERE'S HOW YOU GO FROM A TO BE.
AND THAT IS BY.
INTRODUCTION OF AB TWENTY FIVE
NINETY SIX WHY THIS BILL ASKS.
OF THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE OF
BUSINESS ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT
GOBIZ
TO DEVELOP FOR OUR STATE.
STRATEGIC ACTION PLAN
BUT THE GROWTH OF OUR ECONOMY IN
CONCERT WITH THE STATE'S
BUSINESSES AND OTHER
STAKEHOLDERS.
ARM.
THE.
.
THEY WOULD BE REQUIRED
COMMISSION A STUDY THAT INCLUDES
IDENTIFICATION ECONOMIC GOALS
IMPEDIMENTS OF THOSE GOALS
EVALUATES EFFECTIVE STATES
CURRENT ECONOMIC. PROGRAMS I
HAVE WITH ME VERY BROOM HERE IN
SACRAMENTO. PART OF THE THE
LEADER OF THE GREATER SEPARATE
YOU CAN ON THE COUNCIL AND
CRIMINALIST BURKE OF THE BAY
AREA COUNCIL.
SO THEY'RE DYING TO SEE THOSE
CHARTS GENTLEMAN.
SO MR BROOM IF YOU WILL OPEN AND
WE WILL PROCEED AS IT CAME UP
HERE. THANK YOU LAMBERTON THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE I'M A I'M A ROOKIE
SO. I'LL TRY AND DO A GOOD JOB.
SO.
I'VE BEEN IN CALIFORNIA THREE
YEARS I'VE BEEN AND ECONOMIC
DEVELOPER FOR ABOUT THIRTY YEARS
FROM OHIO IN MICHIGAN.
AND WHEN I FIRST CAME IN THE
CALIFORNIA I WAS AND BUILT A
SORT OF IT ORGANIZATION FROM
SCRATCH I WAS LOOKING FOR THE
PLAN I WOULD PLUG INTO. IT
BECAUSE THE STATE SETS THE
STRATEGIC AND COMPETITIVE
DIRECTION FOR ALL THE
COMMUNITIES YOU KNOW WHAT YOU
DID WAS STEM CELL RESEARCH OPENS
UP THAT MARKET FOR A SACRAMENTO
COMMUNITY. WHAT YOU DO ON
CLIMATE CHANGE IN DEMAND
POLICIES FOR ELECTRIC VEHICLES
WELL THAT ALLOWS US TO BUILD
ELECTRIC VEHICLE CORRIDOR IN A
COMMUNITY LIKE SACRAMENTO? AND.
AND OF COURSE YOU KNOW WHAT I
SAW WAS IN A VERY LARGE COMPLEX
STATE DOING A LOT OF FASCINATING
THINGS AND.
YOU ONE OF THE REASONS THAT.
THE BAY AREA COUNCIL THAT IS
HERE IS I WENT DOWN AND SAW JIM
WONDERMENT AND ASKED HIM ABOUT
TO PLUG INTO A PLAN WITH. THE
BAY AREA COUNCIL THEY WERE MORE
PROMINENT HAD MORE INFLUENCE WE
DID AND SO WE BUILT A MEGA
REGION STRATEGY BETWEEN THE BAY
AREA COUNCIL ON US. AND WE HAVE
THE SAME STRATEGY AROUND CHINA
BUSINESS RETENTION IN NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA NOW STARTING TO SHARE
SOME STRATEGIES AROUND THINGS
LIKE TRANSPORTATION.
THAT HELPS A BAY AREA COUNCIL
BECAUSE THEY GET ANOTHER PARTNER
HIS CLOSE THE STATE CAPITAL THAT
HELPS US BECAUSE WE GET AN
ORGANIZATION WITH REAL LIFTING
POWER AND. WHEN YOU'RE DO YOU'RE
TRYING TO ESTABLISH YOURSELF
BUT ONE OF MY GREAT FRUSTRATIONS
EVEN WHEN I WAS IN A CALIFORNIAN
WAS WATCHING RICK PERRY COME TO
CALIFORNIA. AND TALK ABOUT OUR
STATE AND NOT SEE A MEASURED
RESPONSE TO HIS COMMENTS.
AND IT REALLY FRUSTRATED ME A TO
SEE THAT AND SO ONE OF THE FIRST
THINGS WE DID AS AN ORGANIZATION
RICK SCOTT CAME INTO LOS
ANGELES.
THE GOVERNOR OF FLORIDA TO TAKE
CALIFORNIA BUSINESSES OUT OF
SOUTH CAROLINA. ARE AT A
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA TO FLORIDA.
AND HE WAS TOUTING THE FLORIDA
PORTS
AND OF COURSE THE CALIFORNIA
PRESS WAS DOING THEIR JOB
READING EVERYTHING HE SAID IT
LIKE IT WAS THE GOSPEL. AND
PUTTING THEM ON THE FRONT PAGE
OF ALL OF OUR NEWSPAPERS AND WE
DID THE ANALYSIS AND FOUND OUT
THE LONG BEACH PORT.
BY ITSELF WAS MORE POWERFUL
ECONOMICALLY THAN ALL THE FLOOR
REPORTS COMBINED. SO WE PUT A
LITTLE PRESS RELEASE OUT ON THAT
GOT PICKED UP IN ALL THE FLORIDA
NEWSPAPERS THAT RICK SCOTT SORT
O MADE A FOOL OF HIMSELF IN
CALIFORNIA WITHIN COMPARED OUR
EDUCATIONAL STANDARDS WITH
FLORIDA. WE CAME BACK TO GET
CRITICIZED FOR NOT FOCUSING ON
EDUCATION
NINE I'M SEE RICK SCOTT AGAIN.
INTERSTATE BUT THROUGHOUT
THERE'S OVER A TWELVE STATES
THAT HAVE STRATEGIC PLANS TO
COME THE CALIFORNIA TAKE JOBS
FROM US AND IT'S LISTED BY NAME.
SO I HAVE BOTH AND I WON'T BORE
YOU TO DEATH BUT. THIS IS WHAT
WE GOT WE GO OUT NATIONALLY TO
TWELVE U. S. MARKETS
WE SEND OUT TWO THOUSAND
NATIONAL COMMUNICATIONS EVERY
QUARTER TO THESE NATIONAL
NETWORKS.
AND IF YOU LISTEN TO WHAT PEOPLE
SAY THERE SHOULD BE NINE PEOPLE
LEFT IN CALIFORNIA.
SO WE WERE NOT JUST THE LARGEST
ECONOMY IN THE UNITED STATES
WHERE THE MOST PRODUCTIVE
ECONOMY IN THE UNITED STATES.
AND PRODUCTIVITY AND
PROFITABILITY FOR INDUSTRIES IN
CALIFORNIA DWARFS TEXAS SO
THAT'S JUST A PRODUCTIVITY CHART
WE HAVE A.
PROFITABILITY CHART THAT SHOWS
THAT WE ARE THOUSANDS OF PERCENT
MORE PROFITABLE FOR INDUSTRIES
IN TEXAS
SO YOU GET A ZERO CORPORATE TAX
RATE AND TAXES. ARE IN BUSINESS
TO MAKE MONEY OR IN BUSINESS TO
AVOID TAXES SAID CALIFORNIA
OFFERS A MUCH GREATER
PROFITABILITY POTENTIAL. FOR
FIFTY INDUSTRIES WE ANALYZED
FIFTY INDUSTRIES THAT ARE ALL
MORE PROFITABLE IN CALIFORNIA
THEN AND TAXES.
YET. I WILL I DON'T HAVE A REAL
HAVE LIKE A SLIDE SHOW BUT A
BRING UP THE NEXT SLIDE.
THAT FRUSTRATES ME.
SO THIS IS WHAT THEY THINK
RIGHT.
SO WE GO OUT NATIONALLY WE CAN
BARELY GET A COMMUNICATION OUT.
BECAUSE THIS IS ALL THERE
HEARING RIGHT.
NOW THE BEAUTY OF THIS SITE
SELECTION MAGAZINE WERE
DEMANDING A RETRACTION BECAUSE
WE CUT THEM IN MATH THERE.
SO SITE SELECTION MAGAZINE DID
THE RANKING AND WE CUT THEM IN
MATH FAIRS ON THE TAX POLICY.
SO WE'VE BEEN RATED FIFTIETH AND
TAXES BY SITE SELECTION MAGAZINE
FOR YEARS AND THEY'VE BEEN USING
THE WRONG DATA THEY ARE ALSO
USING THE WRONG DATA ON POWER
COSTS.
SO WE'RE SITTING AROUND THINKING
WOW YOU NO AS A STATE WE'RE
LETTING YOU KNOW THE GOVERNOR OF
ARIZONA THE GOVERNOR OF UTAH THE
GOVERNOR OF IOWA THE GOVERNOR
TAXES. TRAVEL ALL OVER THE
COUNTRY AND SAY THESE THINGS
ABOUT OUR STATE. AND MANY TIMES
WHAT THEY'RE SAYING IS NOT TRUE.
AND YET WEARS A RESPONSE FOR US
IN THE MARKETPLACE THAT'S
ESTABLISHING CALIFORNIA'S BRAND
SO STATEWIDE STRATEGY STARTS
WITH ALL OF US UNDERSTANDING
CALIFORNIA'S STRENGTHS AND HOW
WE TALK ABOUT OUR STATE. THAT WE
TALK ABOUT OUR STATE THAT REALLY
DIFFERENTIATES US AND TELLS HER
STORY.
.
WE'RE PUTTING A CALIFORNIA
COMPETITIVE INDEX TOGETHER
YOU'RE ADDING THINGS LIKE
IMMIGRANTS PATENTS
DIVERSITY VERY POWERFUL ECONOMIC
DRIVERS WELL IF YOU CHANGE THE
FORMULA ON HOW YOU MEASURE
BUSINESS.
VALUE YOU KNOW OUR MARKET
DRAMATICALLY CHANGES IN FACT NY
RANKS.
CALIFORNIA'S EFFECTIVE TAX RATE
ON BUSINESS BETTER THAN TEXAS.
AND BETTER THAN ARIZONA AND
THAT'S ONE OF THE TOP FOUR
PROGRAMS IN THE WORLD TO ME IS
THAT. IN OUR OUR OUR OUR. OUR
PEACHES AND PRESENTATIONS
SO SIMPLY PUT YOU BUILDING A
PLAN WILL ALLOW US ALL WORK WELL
TOGETHER DO IT LESS AD HOC WILL
BE ABLE TO SET A SMARTER.
STRATEGIC DIRECTION BUT I REALLY
WANT TO SEE US TAKE OUR VOICE
BACK IN THE MARKETPLACE AND
START THE CHALLENGE THESE STATES
AND CHALLENGE THESE GOVERNORS
THEY'RE COMING IN OUR STATE.
GOING ON WALL STREET JOURNAL AND
SAYING WILL NEVER BE ANOTHER
CALIFORNIA AND ON AND ON AND ON.
WHEN IN FACT THEY MAY NEVER BE
ANOTHER CALIFORNIA BECAUSE THEY
NEVER BEAT MIGHT NOT BE GOOD
ENOUGH
TO EVER BE A CALIFORNIA. SO.
BETTER STATEWIDE PLAN BETTER
STATEWIDE COORDINATION BETTER
INFORMATION HELP THE SMALLER
MARKETS GET TO THE MARKETPLACE
AND ME AND THE GOBIZ DOES
SLIGHT.
SLIGHT USA'S A GREAT EXAMPLE
GOBIZ DOING GOOD WORK BUT IT'S A
SMALL SHOP
YOU KNOW AND IN SOME PLACES.
YOU KNOW THERE'S TWO OR THREE
HUNDRED PEOPLE DOING THIS WORK
FOR OTHER STATES AND THEY CAN
COVER A LOT OF GROUND IN THE
SMALLER COMMUNITIES COMPLY
AGAIN.
AND SO SMALLER COMMITTEES DON'T
HAVE ROBUST SHOPS PLUGIN TO THE
STATE AGENCY IN PLUG IN THE PLAN
AND FOLLOW ALONG A LITTLE BIT
LIKE HOW WE'RE PLUGGING INTO THE
BAY AREA COUNCIL.
YEAH.
SURE.
THANK YOU.
CROW PUT GOD THANK YOU CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
CORNELIUS BURKE WITH THE BAY
AREA COUNCIL. PLEASE A CO
SPONSOR THE BILL WITH THE
GREATEST ECONOMIC COUNCIL VALLEY
VISION THANK YOU SILLIMAN COOLEY
FREE AUTHORSHIP OF THE BILL.
AS BARRY AND OTHER SAID WE HAVE
DEEP JOB CHALLENGES EGON DEVELOP
CHALLENGES IN OUR STATE THIS
BILL WILL HELP US ADDRESS THAT.
WERE SICK AND TIRED OF.
BUSINESS IS GOING TO TEXAS
ARIZONA UTAH OREGON ENOUGH IS
ENOUGH TODAY TODAY TO STOP THAT
TREND. OF PLEASE PASS AB TWENTY
FIVE NINETY SIX THANK YOU.
YOU ARE SO COMPELLING THAT I
ACTUALLY LOST TRACK OF TIME I
THINK IT'S PROBABLY THE. FIRST
HEARING IN THE ED MY TIME UP
HERE THAT I WAS SO MESMERIZED BY
BUT ALL OF YOU ARE SAYING AND I
REALLY. UP ON IT SAYING BEFORE
WE GO ON TOUR SUPPORT ON THIS
MESSAGING PLAN. BECAUSE.
FOR MANY YEARS WELL OVER A
DECADE STARTING WITH MY OF
FULLERTON CITY COUNCIL DAYS. AND
NOW BEING UP HERE YOU JUST
CONTINUE TO HEAR THE SAME THING
OVER AND OVER AND OVER THAT YOU
ALMOST START TO BELIEVE THAT.
AND YET LIKE YOU SAY THE FACTS
ORINDA WE THE FACTS ARE REALLY
WHERE THE TRUTH LIES BUT WHEN
YOU HEAR THE SAME MESSAGE YOU
KNOW.
THAT CALIFORNIA ISN'T MAKING
THE CUT AND THAT CERTAINLY
DOESN'T MEAN LIKE YOU STARTED
WITH WE DON'T HAVE WORK TO DO.
PARTICULARLY IN REGIONAL AREAS
BUT I'M REALLY I'M NOT ONLY
THANKFUL THAT THIS BILL HAS COME
THROUGH BUT I. I DEFINITELY.
WOULD LIKE WE ALREADY HAVE A
REQUEST FROM A FOR A CO AUTHOR
FOR MR GARCIA HE SAID MAN NOPE
HE'S COMING BACK. BUT I KNOW
THAT THIS THIS HAS THE CAPACITY.
TO CHANGE EVERYTHING WE DO ROM
THAT STARTING AT THE TOP AND
EVEN THOUGH WE ARE VERY PROUD OF
THE BILL'S WE'VE PUT FORWARD.
I'VE NEVER REALLY SAT IN A
COMMITTEE WHERE YOU'RE TAKING A
A REAL KIND A MACRO LEVEL INSANE
WHO ARE WE IN CALIFORNIA AND
WOULD WE WANT TO BE. AND SO IF
IT'S JUST AS SIMPLE AS I FEEL
LIKE I NEED MY LITTLE
CHEERLEADER POM POMS APPEARED TO
SAY. YOU KNOW WE WE SUPPORT
CALIFORNIA AND SO SINCE WE HAVE
SO MANY BUSINESS REPRESENTATIVES
HERE I WOULD SAY THAT STARTS
TODAY. AND IT STARTS FOR ME YOU
KNOW AND IT STARTS FROM US
BECAUSE WHO IS BETTER THAN TECH
TO PUMP UP OUR STATE AND SAY
COME HERE AND. DO THE WELCOME
FLAG AND HAVE THE BANNERS
BECAUSE IF WE DON'T DO IT
SOMEBODY ELSE IS DOING IT IN SEE
RIGHT THERE THAT NICE POSTER
THOSE ARE THE TYPE OF VOICES
THAT ARE DEFINING CALIFORNIA. SO
I THINK THIS IS GREAT SO IF
YOU'RE IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL
PLEASE LET US KNOW AND I'M
WELCOME AND WILL COME BACK TO
MEMBERS COMMENTS AS WELL.
GOOD MORNING MELISSA AND MO WITH
CHAYTOR ANTI ON BEHALF OF THE
PLASTER COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS IN SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE PLUG INS OFFICE
REPRESENTING THE CITIES OF ELK
GROVE FOLSOM AND ROSEVILLE AND
SPUR THE BILL WE LIKE TO THINK
THE AUTHOR.
GOOD MORNING ANDREW LANGLEY ON
BEHALF OF THE COUNTY OF WROTE
YELLOWING SUPPORT THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING SEAN DOES THE
NATIONAL FEDERATION OF
INDEPENDENT BUSINESS ALSO
SUPPORT THINKING.
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR I'M THE
CEO OF LARRY ALLBAUGH FOR
BUZZARDS HERE LOCALLY IN
SACRAMENTO. AND MORE IMPORTANTLY
THE FATHER OF A SON WHO WILL BE
GRADUATING IS A U. S. ARMY
OFFICER FROM CAL STATE FULLERTON
NEXT MONTH SO.
HER RIGHT TYSON'S FODDER AHEAD
SO I'D LIKE TO TO JUST VOICE MY
SUPPORT FOR THIS SAID. VERY
SIMPLY AS A AS A BUSINESS OWNER
AND WHO RUNS A TEAM.
WE SEE THE VALUE OF STRATEGIC
FOCUS.
AND ACCOUNTABLE PERFORMANCE
AND THIS BILL AS WE'VE SEEN
HAPPEN WITH GREATER SACRAMENTO
HERE LOCALLY WITH NINETEEN
MUNICIPALITIES AND THIRTY CEOS
COMING TOGETHER TO DO THE SAME.
THIS BILL POINTS IS TO WEAR THAT
SAME SIMPLE PRINCIPLE OF
ACCOUNTABLE PERFORMANCE BASED ON
METRICS.
AND THE DATA THAT THAT REALLY
PROVIDES A DIFFERENT STORY SO I
SUPPORT THANKS.
YOU.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE AGAIN DAY BUT
REPRESENT UNITED CHAMBER
ADVOCACY NETWORK FIVE LOCAL
CHAMBERS HERE IN THE SACRAMENTO
MARKETPLACE.
I'M JUST VERY SIMPLY HAVE
REPRESENTING BUSINESSES EVERY
BUSINESS NEEDS A BUSINESS PLAN
IN ORDER TO DEMONSTRATE. THEIR
POSITION THEMSELVES FOR SUCCESS
IN ATTRACT CAPITAL.
EVERY JURISDICTION CITY COUNTY
AND STATE NEEDS A BUSINESS PLAN
TO DO THE SAME SO WERE VERY MUCH
A AND SUPPORT AND PRE SHIP OF
THE AUTHORS. BIPARTISAN COMMON
SENSE BILL THANK YOU.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS COURTNEY
JENSEN THE CALIFORNIA CREDIT
UNION LEAGUE ALSO IN SUPPORT.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS ALL ROCK OR
A CALIFORNIA LIFE SCIENCES
ASSOCIATION OUT WE ARE THE
BIRTHPLACE OF BIOTECH.
THIS BILL ENSURES THAT WE CAN
KEEP THAT MOVING THE RIGHT BY.
SINCE ON VERY STRONG SUPPORT THE
BILL THINK THE AUTHOR.
DRAW COOK FOR THE CALIFORNIA
MANUFACTURERS AND TECHNOLOGY
ASSOCIATION IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
THE BILL.
GOOD MORNING CARE RUSSELL BEHALF
OF THE CITY OF SACRAMENTO IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
MORE TOP ON BEHALF OF ORANGE
COUNTY BUSINESS COUNCIL IN
SUPPORT.
HEIDI PIGMENT FROM THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION FOR MICRO
ENTERPRISE OPPORTUNITY HOUSE
ONCE PER THIS BILL.
ONE LAST THING A BIGGER PART OF
WHAT I CALL YOUR ATTENTION TO A
COALITION LETTER THAT WE DROPPED
ON THE COMMITTEE THANK YOU THANK
YOU.
WELL THE CORPORATION WE SUPPORT
THIS BILL.
BUT DO WE HAVE ANY MEMBERS HERE
IN OPPOSITION.
SEEN NOW NONE WILL.
.
WE HAVE A MOTION TO MOVE A A
SECOND. AND A BEFORE AT CLOSING
COMMENTS DO WE HAVE ANY OTHER
COMMENTS FROM OUR MEMBERS UP
HERE.
DO WE WHAT WHAT WOULD WE LIKE
TO ADD ANYBODY AS A PRINCIPAL
CHO AUTHOR.
I WOULD I WELCOME ALL. AND I DO
WANT TO POINT OUT OF MY COAUTHOR
ON THIS IS KEVIN KILEY MY
COLLEAGUE.
SO THAT THE TWO LAWYERS FROM THE
EAST COUNTY PARTNERING ON THIS.
VERY ABLE PARK SO I WAS REMISS
IN NOT POINTING THAT OUT AT THE
OUTSET.
YEAH. YEAH. WELL AGAIN I
APPRECIATE THIS OF THAT
LEGISLATION COMING THROUGH I I
CAN DEFINITELY SEE WHERE OF THIS
EXERCISE AS FAR AS REALLY
DEFINING WHO WE ARE.
WHAT OUR GOALS OR I CAN I HAVE
A SPEAKING THE SAME LANGUAGE AND
IT CAN YOU IMAGINE IF THERE ARE
THOUSANDS OF ONLY BUSINESS
OWNERS BUT REPRESENTATIVES
WHETHER THEY BE FROM CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE? SMALL DEVOID OF
BUSINESS DEVELOPMENT WORK FOR SO
FORTH HAVING THE SAME MESSAGE.
THAT IS A POSITIVE A MESSAGE TO
BRING BUSINESS TO CALIFORNIA
THAT THAT INDEED.
EIGHT BUT THE WAY YOU
MESSAGE YOURSELF IS OFTEN THE
RETURN YOU GET SO I THINK YOU SO
MUCH WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
I REQUEST AN AYE VOTE.
ALRIGHT MISTERS US SECRETARY.
ITEM NUMBER TWO ASSEMBLY BILL
TWENTY FIVE NINETY SIX.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
AND RE REFER TO ASSEMBLY
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
CHAIR QUIRK SILVA AYE.
CHAIR QUIRK SILVA AYE. VICE
CHAIR ALAN Y..
VICE CHAIR ELENA COOLEY AYE.
COOLEY AYE.
BERMAN.
CERVANTES.
CERVANTES AYE.
GARCIA.
STEINORTH.
STEINORTH I.
OKAY THAT BILL IS ON CALL AND
THANK YOU FOR YOUR PRESENTATION.
ALRIGHT. WE ARE GOING TO CALL UP
ASSEMBLY MEMBER RATE IS TO
PRESENT AB TWO NINE SEVEN FOUR
LOCAL LOCAL WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT BOARD.
WELCOME ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS.
TODAY AND PRESENTING A. B. TWO
NINE SEVEN FOUR. BILL WHICH AIMS
TO BETTER POWER SMALL LOCAL
BUSINESSES BY ENSURING THAT THEY
HAVE ADEQUATE SUPPORT FOR PUBLIC
CONTRACTING.
OPPORTUNITIES.
SPECIFICALLY WITH COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS OWN.
THIS BILL WOULD REQUIRE.
LOCAL WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT
BOARD'S TO PROVIDE SUPPORT TO
THE EFFORTS OF EMPLOYERS. TO
ALIGN WITH PUBLIC CONTRACTING
NEEDS IN A MANNER THAT WILL
SUPPORT LOCAL WORKFORCE
OPPORTUNITIES.
IN TWO THOUSAND FOURTEEN
PRESIDENT OBAMA SIGNED THE
WORKFORCE INNOVATION AND
OPPORTUNITIES ACT.
WHICH SET NEW STANDARDS FOR
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT
NATIONWIDE.
THE ACT ALONG WITH STATE LAW
REQUIRES THAT BOARD TO LEAD
EFFORTS
TO ENGAGE WITH A DIVERSE RANGE
OF EMPLOYERS AND STAKEHOLDERS TO
ACHIEVE THE GOALS.
THESE GOALSINCLUDE PROMOTING
BUSINESS
REPRESENTATION ON BOARDS AND
DEVELOPING EFFECTIVE LINKAGES
WITH EMPLOYERS.
SUPPORT THE UTILIZATION THE
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT CENTERS.
PORTING ECONOMIC GROWTH.
LOCAL WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT
BOARD'S ARE TRULY WORKING AT THE
GROUND LEVEL AND HAVE AN INNATE
UNDERSTANDING OF BUSINESS AND
WORKFORCE NEEDS.
DO TO THEIR LOCAL INTERACTION
WITH EMPLOYERS AND EMPLOYEES.
REGULARLY STATE CONTRACTING CAN
BE COMPLICATED.
THAT CAN BE OUT COMPLICATED TO
ACCESS FOR LOCAL EMPLOYERS AS A
SICK TO FIND OPPORTUNITIES THAT
WILL ALLOW THEM TO GROW AND
DRIVE LOCAL WORKFORCE DEMANDS.
THIS MAKES IT IMPERATIVE THAT WE
DO EVERYTHING WE CAN TO INCLUDE
ALL REGIONS OF THE STATE AND
EMPOWER THEM WITH THE LOCAL
ASSISTANCE TO THRIVE.
I WOULD LIKE TO ONCE AGAIN THANK
THE CALIFORNIA WORKFORCE
ASSOCIATION FOR CONTINUING TO
ENGAGE MY OFFICE ON THIS TOPIC.
I AM CONFIDENT THAT WE WILL BE
ABLE TO REACH THIS BILLS GOAL OF
EMPOWERING LOCAL ECONOMIES.
AB TWENTY NINE SEVENTY FOUR IS
SUPPORTED BY THE SAMBA DO YOU
KNOW CHAMBER OF COMMERCE.
AS WELL AS A ST BERNARD DO YOU
KNOW AS WELL AS A SMALL BUSINESS
CALIFORNIA. HERE TO SPEAK ON
BEHALF OF SMALL BUSINESS
CALIFORNIA IS LAURIE KRAMMER.
WELCOME THANK YOU GOOD MORNING
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS LAURIE
CAMERON WITH SMALL BUSINESS
CALIFORNIA WE REPRESENT ABOUT
FIVE THOUSAND SMALL BUSINESSES
THROUGHOUT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. I ALSO WANT TO ADD
THAT I'M HERE ON BEHALF OF THE
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF WOMEN
BUSINESS OWNERS ELEVEN CHAPTERS
IN CALIFORNIA. AND WE SUPPORT
THIS BILL.
BOTH GROUPS PARTICIPATE ON THE
DEPARTMENT OF GENERAL SERVICES.
SMALL BUSINESS ADVISORY COUNCIL
AND IT HAS ALWAYS BEEN.
A CONCERN AND ALSO OUT OF GREAT
INTEREST THAT WE.
NEED TO KNOW MORE ABOUT
CONTRACTING OPPORTUNITIES AND
WORKING MORE WITH THE
DEVELOPMENT PORTS IS EXACTLY
WHAT THIS BILL DOES SO WE ARM
GRATEFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I FELT
THINKING.
THANK YOU.
OH OKAY.
A WITH THAT DO WE HAVE ANY
MEMBERS THAT HAVE ANY QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS.
AND.
DO WE HAVE ANYBODY ELSE IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
WELCOME.
MADAM CHAIR AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS ERIC FLOORS AT THE
CALIFORNIA WORKFORCE ASSOCIATION
NOT IN SUPPORT NOT IN OPPOSITION
JUST HAVE SOME.
CONCERNS AND COMMENTS ABOUT THE
BILL WE'D LIKE TO.
MAKE KNOWN TODAY.
WE HAVE SOME CONCERNS AROUND
THE DUPLICATIVE NATURE OF THIS
WORK WITH RELATION TO WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT BOARDS IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA. MOSTLY THAT WE
FEEL THIS MAY BE BETTER SERVED
FIRST ALL.
STATE SMALL BUSINESS
DEVELOPMENT CENTERS TO WORK ON.
WE WANT TO REITERATE WE'RE NOT
OPPOSED AYE WE CONTINUE TO WANT
TO WORK WITH THE.
MEMBER WE DO HOWEVER HAVE
SERIOUS RESERVATIONS ABOUT THE
PROPOSED COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS.
FEELING THAT THEY WOULD BE
HUGELY DUPLICATIVE TO CURRENTLY
EXISTING STRUCTURES BOTH AT THE
LOCAL WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT. A
BOARD LEVEL AND IT COUNTY AGENCY
LEVEL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
I WE ASK FOR. OPPOSITION AND YES
WELCOME.
AND CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION FOR
MICROENTERPRISE OPPORTUNITY HOW
DEEP YOU CAN SUPPORT THIS BILL.
AND WE GET A MOTION TO MOVE IN A
SECOND AND I HAVE A JUST A FEW
COMMENTS ON ON THIS.
LEGISLATION. YOU KNOW AS A
TEACHER FOR MANY YEARS I THINK
THAT ONE OF THE THINGS THAT I'VE
SEEN IS MANY.
INDIVIDUALS NEED CERTAIN TYPES
OF PRESENTATIONS IN ORDER TO
REALLY MAKE THEIR WAY THROUGH A
PROCESS AND SOMETIMES UP ONE A
GROUP MAY PRESENT SOMETHING IN
ONE WAY ANOTHER. A DIFFERENT WAY
BUT I'VE SEEN THAT THE MORE
EXPLICIT WE CAN BE.
THE MORE.
FORTHCOMING ABOUT WHAT IS THE
PROCESS THEN WE CAN START TO
ENSURE THAT THERE'S EQUITY.
AND DELIVERING THE FUNDS THAT
WE HAVE A WHETHER IT BE UNDER.
STATE CONTRACTS WHETHER IT BE I
JUST ACCESSING AND I KNOW THAT
IN MANY OF OUR REGIONS ACCESS
SEEMS TO BE A AN ISSUE WE HAVE A
WHOLE NOTHER PIECE OF
LEGISLATION THAT ISN'T THIS ONE
IN ONE OF. THE MANY DISCUSSIONS
WE'VE HAD WITH THAT LEGISLATION.
IS WHEN PEOPLE I DON'T GO
THROUGH A PROCESS THE CORRECT
WAY A LOT OF TIMES THERE A
PACKAGE OF INFORMATION GETS
STUCK AND LATER ON THEY FIND OUT
OKAY WE DIDN'T REALLY
UNDERSTANDS THAT. AND SOMEBODY
WHO'S UP BEEN DOING IT MANY MANY
TIMES MAYBE THEY'RE A REGULAR IF
YOU WANT TO SAY THAT AT AXIS
SEE.
STATE FUNDS THEY ZIP THROUGH IT
AND.
THIS THIS IS ALL OVER THE BOARD
WHETHER IT BE APPLYING FOR
GRANTS WERE YOU KNOW WITH THE
MORE. OPPORTUNITY YOU HAVE TO GO
THROUGH A PROCESS THE BETTER YOU
GET BUT WHEN WE REALLY LOOK AT
THE NEWCOMERS AND AND SMALL
BUSINESSES EVEN TWO TO THREE AND
THEY WANT TO LOOK AT DO THEY
HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY. TO COMPETE
SOMETIMES THEY DON'T BECAUSE
THEY DON'T HAVE UP THE THE TEAM
PUT TOGETHER THAT THAT HAS THE
FULL.
ABED KIND OF WORKFORCE HOURS
THAT THEY NEED TO SPEND ON THIS
SO I SEE THIS AS A WAY TO KIND
OF LEVEL THE PLAYING FIELD IN
MAKING
SURE THAT. THAT.
WHETHER IT'S THREE EMPLOYEES OR
MAJOR.
GROUP THAT THEY ALL CAN MAKE
SURE THEY CAN ACCESS WHAT WE
PROVIDE THROUGH THE STATE SO
WITHOUT I DO SUPPORT THE BILL WE
HAVE A MOTION A SECOND.
MISTER SECRETARY.
ITEM NUMBER FIVE ASSEMBLY BILL
TWENTY NINE SEVENTY FOR THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AND RE REFER
TO THE ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS.
CHAIR QUIRK SILVA.
CHAIR QUIRK SILVA AYE.
VICE CHAIR ALAN.
VICE CHAIR ALLEN AYE.
COOLEY.
COOLEY AYE BERMAN.
CERVANTES.
CERVANTES AYE.
GARCIA.
STEINORTH.
STEINORTH I.
OKAY THIS BILL GOING CALL THANK
YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER RAY S. AND
TEAM. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS ALRIGHT SO I THINK I AM
GOING TO BE THE LAST PRESENTER
AND A SOME VICE CHAIR.
MISTER ALLEN YOU'RE GONNA BE.
HEADING THIS UP.
THANK YOU FOR JOINING US MR
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WE MISSED YOU SO
MUCH.
RIGHT HERE.
FULLER DIDN. GOOD GOOD.
THANKS.
WHERE IS OUR ITEM NUMBER?
I KNOW COOPER AFFECT IT.
I LOVE IT.
OKAY NEXT UP IS I AB TWENTY SIX
EIGHTY SEVEN.
LIKE TO PRESENT.
YES THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS I'M HAPPY TO PRESENT AB
TWENTY SIX EIGHTY SEVEN WHICH IS
THE OFFICE OF THE SMALL BUSINESS
ADVOCATE.
AND DATA I WANT TO ACCEPT THE
COMMITTEES.
AMENDMENTS
AND ALTHOUGH I BELIEVE WE HAVE
SIX OF SIX OF THOSE AN WITH THIS
DOES IS ACTUALLY INTEGRATES
SMALL BUSINESS ADVOCATE WITH THE
THE STATE'S EXISTING DISASTER.
UP PREPAREDNESS RESPONSE AND
RECOVERY ACTIVITIES.
UNFORTUNATELY THIS LAST YEAR WE
SAW A SEASON IN CALIFORNIA OF ON
PRESIDENT.
NOT ONLY FIRES BUT FLOODS AND.
EVERYTHING ELSE IN BETWEEN AND
THIS REALLY BROUGHT FOR FORWARD.
HOW'RE WE COORDINATING WHO IS
RESPONSIBLE AFTER THESE EVENTS A
QUIRK OCCUR AND IF YOU ARE A
BUSINESS.
OWNER HOW DO YOU BEGIN TO
NAVIGATE WHAT DO YOU DO AFTER
EVERYTHING IS LOST WHO WAS THE
FIRST PERSON TO GO TO WE KNOW.
IF IT'S AN HOMEOWNER OF COURSE
THEY'RE GOING TO GO TO UP
PERHAPS THEIR INSURANCE CARRIER
BUT IF YOU'RE A BUSINESS YOU MAY
NOT HAVE ALL OF THOSE.
THAT TYPE OF INFORMATION IN
PLACE AND THEY NEED AN ADVOCATE
SO THIS WOULD CLARIFY THE ROLE
OF THE ADVERT KIT WITHIN THE
SMALL BUSINESS PROCUREMENT AND
REGULATORY ASSISTANT ACTIVITIES.
I AM ALSO JOINTLY AUSTRIAN THIS
BILL WITH THE SUDDENLY MEMBER
LOW MOAN WHO SOME OF YOU WILL
REMEMBER WHAT THAT MIGHT TO
SETO.
FLOODS IT WAS DIRECTLY INVOLVED
IN MUCH OF THIS DISCUSSION AND
ACTIVITY WITHIN HER COMMUNITY
AYE AND WE ALSO I'VE ASKED.
JESSE TOWARDS THE CALIFORNIA
SMALL BUSINESS ADVOCATE TO JOIN
US BUT.
HE'S NOT HERE TODAY SO OF BUT IT
IT'S AS SIMPLE BUT NEEDED AND SO
I WOULD ASK FOR YOUR IPHONE.
BILLS MOVE BILLS NEWMAN SECONDED
ARE THERE ARE AMENDMENTS AND
YOU'VE ACCEPTED ALL THE MEMBERS
CORRECT YES ARISE ANYONE ELSE
WHO'D LIKE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT.
ANY WITNESSES AGAINST.
OKAY THE BILLS AND MOVED INSIDE
AND OUT OF SECTORS LIKE CALLED
WANT TO POINT OUT THAT THIS IS
AN EXCELLENT. BILL.
YOU KNOW THE SMALL BUSINESS
ISSUES AND DISASTERS ARE ALMOST
UNIMAGINABLE.
BASIC ISSUES OF HOW DOES DOES
THE SMALL BUSINESS PERSON HAVE
BUSINESS INTERRUPTION INSURANCE
TO THE KNOW HOW TO MAKE A CLAIM.
THERE'S
THOSE SORTS OF ISSUES THAT
ARISE.
BUT THEN IT'S LIKE IT'S JUST
MIND BLOWING THE TYPES OF ISSUES
COME THAT COME UP.
AFTER.
.
AFTER THE.
DOWNTOWN MALL IN SANTA CRUZ FELL
DOWN THE LOWER PRESSURE
EARTHQUAKE.
WE HAD CENTURY OLD BUILDINGS
THAT COLLAPSED.
ONE OF THE ISSUES AROSE A SMALL
BUSINESSES.
GOT BLINDSIDED WITH WAS THE
POSSIBILITY THAT. DOWN IN THE
MUD OF THEIR FOUNDATIONS NOW
EXPOSED TO LIGHT AND WATER.
AFTER CENTURIES BEING HIDDEN
AWAY.
THAT SOME PLANTS UNIQUE TO
CALIFORNIA MIGHT. BLOOM.
AND COMPLICATE REBUILDING.
SO THERE'S JUST IT'S ALMOST
UNIMAGINABLE HOW DISASTERS CAN
SORT OF RESET THE TABLE WREAK.
BRING COMPLICATION HOW YOU
RECOVER. ALL ALL THE HOOPS YOU
HAVE TO GO THROUGH IF YOU HAVE
TO HAVE TEMPORARY FACILITIES AS
WAS DONE FOR ABOUT A YEAR WITH
THE PACIFIC GARDEN ALL THAT'S
THE SANTA CRUZ THING.
SO I ACTUALLY FEEL A.
FOR THE ECONOMIC VITALITY IS
COMMITTEES WHICH ARE OF COURSE
ESSENTIAL TO HOW THE
NEIGHBORHOOD FOR.
VERY IMPORTANT PIECE OF THE
PUZZLE SO I COMMEND YOU FOR THIS
GREAT GREAT IDEA.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER GUY COME
THROUGH COMMITTEE MEMBERS WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE. BY YES YES I
I A. AS WAS NOTED THIS ISN'T A
GIANT BILL IN THE SCHEME OF
CALIFORNIA BUT OUT WHEN WE CAN
HELP SOMEBODY WHO IS SET UP AND
TAKEN THE RISK THEMSELVES TO
OPEN A BUSINESS IN CALIFORNIA
AND DISASTER STRIKES WE NEED TO
HAVE SOMEBODY THEY CAN GO TO.
SO I ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE WITH
THAT THE RECOMMENDATION IS AYE
MEN OF SEXUAL WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CALL THE ROLL.
MISTER SECRETARY O. AREA BUT
ALRIGHT.
ITEM NUMBER FOUR ASSEMBLY BILL
TWENTY SIX EIGHTY SEVEN THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
INTO RE REFER TO THE ASSEMBLY
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS.
CHAIR QUIRK SILVA AYE AYE.
CHAIR QUIRK SILVA AYE.
PLACE YOUR ALLEN.
VICE CHAIR ALLEN AYE COOLEY.
COOLEY AYE BERMAN.
CERVANTES.
CERVANTES AYE GARCIA.
STEINORTH.
STEINORTH I.
WITH THAT.
ORDER FINAL FINAL COUNT ON THE.
BILL PASSES.
THANK YOU VICE CHAIR. ALLEN
ALRIGHT WE ARE GOING TO GO AHEAD
AND.
OPEN THE RULE FOR ANY VOTES
THAT WERE NOT COUNTED AND THEN.
AND WILL KEEP THE ROLE OPEN FOR
ABOUT.
TWO MINUTES.
WE'LL KEEP WE WILL KEEP THE ROLE
OPEN AND THEN LEFT IT DIDN'T TWO
MINUTES
SO ALL RIGHT MISTER CHAIR I MEAN
MISTER SECRETARY.
SO HE.
THAT'S OKAY WE'RE FINE JUST
BECAUSE I THINK MISTER ALLEN HAD
A FEW VOTES THAT HE DIDN'T GET.
YEAH THAT THAT'S FINE.
OKAY THANK YOU MEMBERS FOR
JOINING US.
INCLUDING.
I'LL TAKE THOSE POSTERS.
OKAY.
SOON.
OIL ARE IT OF MISTER CHAIR WE
START WITH ITEM ONE.
ITEM ONE ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY
THREE TWELVE MOTION IS DO PASS
AS AMENDED AND RE REFER TO THE
ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE ON REVENUE
AND TAXATION. VICE CHAIR ALAN
ARE.
VICE CHAIR ALLEN AYE.
BERMAN.
BERMAN I.
SEVEN ZERO THE BILL WAS OUT.
AND ITEM TO.
ITEM TWO ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY
FIVE NINETY SIX.
THE MOTION IS DO PASS AS AMENDED
AND RE REFER TO ASSEMBLY
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS.
BERMAN.
BERMAN I.
GARCIA.
WE'RE GONNA KEEP THAT OPEN.
AN ITEM THREE.
ITEM THREE ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY
FOUR SIXTY THREE.
THE MOTION IS DO PASS AS AMENDED
AND RE REFER TO ASSEMBLY
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS VICE
CHAIR ALAN AYE AYE.
VICE CHAIR ALLEN AYE BERMAN.
BERMAN I.
THAT BILL IS OUT ITEM FOR.
ITEM FOUR ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY
FIVE.
SIX EIGHTY SEVEN THE MOTION IS
DO PASS AS AMENDED AND RE REFER
TO THE ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS.
BERMAN.
BERMAN AYE GARCIA.
THAT BIT WE WILL LEAVE THAT OPEN
FOR A FEW MINUTES AND ITEM FIVE.
ITEM FIVE ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY
NINE SEVENTY FOUR THE MOTION IS
DO PASS AND RE REFER TO THE
ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS. BERMAN.
BERMAN AYE. GARCIA.
WE WILL ALSO LEAVE THAT OPEN FOR
A FEW MINUTES THANK YOU MEMBERS
FOR COMING. THANK YOU EVERYBODY.
STAY ONE MINUTE.
PERFECT ELLIS TO.
RUNNING.
I MEAN.
OKAY.
WHAT IS HE?
BUSINESS DAY FOR.
AREAS ARE UNDER LUXURY FOR YOU.
THE LATEST PICTURE OF THE BABY
ALL.
WOULD YOU PLEASE.
YEAH THAT'S WHAT I MEAN THAT'S
WHAT I'M DOING JUST WITH ITEMS
THAT THAT COMES
.
LEGISLATION OF THE BILL.
WE CALLING JUST EXCHANGE THE.
ALRIGHT MR SECRETARY CAN WE
CALL.
ITEM TO.
ITEM TO SIMPLY BUILD TWENTY FIVE
NINETY SIX THE MOTION IS DO PASS
AS AMENDED IN RE REFER TO
ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS.
GARCIA.
GARCIA I.
THAT BILL IS OUT SEVEN ZERO ITEM
FOR.
ITEM FOR ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY
SIX EIGHTY SEVEN THE MOTION IS
DO PASS AS AMENDED AND RE REFER
TO THE ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS GARCIA.
GARCIA I.
AND THAT BILL IS OUT. SEVEN
ZERO.
ITEM FIVE.
ITEM FIVE ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY
NINE SEVENTY FOR THE MOTION IS
DO PASS AND RE REFER TO THE
ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS. GARCIA.
GARCIA I THAT BILL IS OUT SEVEN
ZERO THANK YOU MISTER SECRETARY
AND ASSEMBLY MEMBER GARCIA THANK
YOU FOR ATTENDING OUR HEARING